just have to say you're so spirited I I
just want to put you in a box and saw
you in half for magic as a part of a
trick he does magic right it's only
weird if you don't embrace good dude
explain yourself I'll be honest I
completely blacked out how do i do men
honestly seen you do worse lost things
come back with you I don't wanna die
Elise
you have a long life ahead of you I
cross my heart what does that mean how
is the 10 so it's a hundred times
stronger now don't worry Caltech is
probably the safest place to be right
now professor it looks like the whole
San Andreas Fault Line is being
activated and it's heading towards San
Francisco I don't really want to each of
these are filled with chloroform wow
that is an unsettling amount of
hemorrhoid wipes makes me kind of wonder
Quinn exactly's going on back there I
wouldn't know I don't have that problem
I don't have that problem do not fire
with 12 amps in these animals they're
never gonna trust me again Lou stand
down stand down hey hey what did I just
say Delta I see you back up okay